[موسيقى]
خلال الساعات اللي فاتت ممكن تكون لاحظت
وجود رمز كمثرى في الوصف الشخصي لحسابات
اصدقائك على موقع انستجرام فلو ما كنتش
تعرف السبب هحكي لك القصه
كلمه السر هي بير بير هي الشركه قررت تعمل
تجربه اطلقت عليها اكبر تجربه اجتماعيه في
العالم والفكره هي ان كل العزاب خصوصا
اللي عايزين يعلنوا استعدادهم للارتباط
يضيفوا رمز كمثرى للوصفه لشخصي بحساباتهم
على موقع انستجرام وتكون دي طريقه للفت
انتباه الاشخاص المنجذبين ليهم وتوضيح
لحالتهم العاطفيه
التجربه حظت بتفاعل كبير وواسع في كل
العالم وفي وقت قصير جدا وشجعك كمان شركه
بير العزاب انهم يلبسوا خواتم خضراء بترمز
للعزوبيه ووضحه ان لو مليون ونص عازب
لبسوا الخواتم دي بعد انتشار مفهومها مش
هنحتاج تطبيقات المواعده مره تانيه وده
لان هيكون من السهل معرفه من هو وحيد من
حولك ومنفتح لمقابله اشخاص جدد وخوض تجارب
عاطفيه
وهنا اتقسمت المناقشه حول التجربه لمحورين
الاول هو فكره استحواذ الرموز التعبيريه
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي على عالم
المواعده لان حتى المرتبطين في اغلب
الاحيان بيكونوا ضايفين رموز متشابهه في
الوصف الشخصي لحسابتهم
[موسيقى]
اما المحور التاني فهو فكره اعلان
العزوبيه في حد ذاتها فكان في مؤيدين
لوجود خاتم مضاد لخاتم الزواج والخطوبه
بحيث يكون في خاتم بيرمز لكل حاله
اجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
في حين ان البعض شاف ان مفيش داعي لاعلان
العزوبيه ولفت الانظار فالمهتم لامريكا
حقا سيجد لقلبك طريق
وين الكمثرى